- [Interviewer] All right Bob.
- Yes.
- Bob, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Bob] I'm originally
from Brooklyn, New York.
- [Interviewer] And tell
me about your childhood.
You had both your parents
when you were a kid?
- [Bob] No, I was raised
by my grandparents.
- [Interviewer] What
happened to mom and dad?
- Didn't like each other
so my granddad took me.
They divorced.
My parents divorced and I
wound up with my grandparents.
- [Interviewer] How would
you describe your childhood?
- Okay.
Okay.
- [Interviewer] Nothing
going on that was awful?
- Not until I turned 17,
and then I went off to Vietnam.
- [Interviewer] Tell me about Vietnam.
- Not much fun. It was not a good thing.
No, it was not a good thing.
No.
- [Interviewer] What did you do
after you came back from Vietnam?
- I lived here. I moved right here.
And then I worked on the oil platforms
most of my life.
And,
I've got a daughter and two grandkids,
and I give them my retirement.
- [Interviewer] And you've been living
in the Tenderloin for how long?
- About two years.
- [Interviewer] But you've
in the Bay Area since when?
- I moved over there in North beach,
it's probably 16 years.
17 years.
- But you moved here from-
- And then I moved up
over the hill to the TL.
- [Interviewer] Okay, but you
lived in the Bay Area since-
- Oh, 40 years?
- 40 years?
- Yeah, 40.
- [Interviewer] How old are you now?
- I'm 70.
- 70.
And there's a lot of drugs
here in the Tenderloin.
Has drugs been a part of your life too?
- Not really.
I stay to myself.
- [Interviewer] Do you have friends?
- Yeah, I got a couple.
- [Interviewer] And you were married once?
- Oh yeah.
Yeah, she passed away about...
It was five, six years ago.
- [Interviewer] Oh, I'm sorry.
And looking back at your life,
what regrets do you have?
- Oh, I really don't know.
I really don't know.
I think I've had a fairly
decent life, nothing tragic.
Till my wife died.
- [Interviewer] You would say
you had a pretty good life?
- Yeah, I believe so. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Are you religious?
- No, I'm not very religious guy.
- [Interviewer] What's been
the best time of your life?
- Best time in my life?
I've had a pretty good life.
I guess when I got married and stuff
would be about the best time of my life.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And what's
been the roughest time?
Roughest thing you went through.
- When my wife got the cancer.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
Yeah, that would do it.
What would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life?
The most important lesson?
- Not really, I don't know.
Probably, lesson I've
learned is pretty much
don't trust anybody.
- [Interviewer] I hear that a lot.
- That's why I was sort of skeptic
when you first talked to me.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
It's a strange request from a stranger.
Do you believe in karma?
- I do.
Sure.
What goes around comes around.
I believe in that for sure.
- [Interviewer] And you'd
been in love before.
It sounds like with your wife?
- Excuse me?
- [Interviewer] You've
been in love before.
- Before my wife?
- [Interviewer] I assume you had.
- Oh, the high school girlfriend
and that kind of thing.
- [Interviewer] But you
felt loved as a child?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Your grandparents.
- Oh, very much so.
- Do you think the fact
that your real parents
were not so much in your
life had an effect on you?
Or you or your grandparents
did a good job of-
- [Bob] I think my grandparents
did a very good job
taking care of me.
- [Interviewer] It's great
that they were there for you.
- [Bob] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And what do you think
of this life here in the Tenderloin where-
- [Bob] It sucks.
- [Interviewer] Where
drugs are so prevalent.
- [Bob] Yeah, it just sucks.
It's just evil.
- [Interviewer] What do you think
the solution to that problem is?
Because it destroys so many lives.
- [Bob] Oh God.
I don't know.
'Cause I can't say anything
about anybody else,
because I'm a fucking junkie.
No, I can't say anything about anybody.
How you're gonna fix
it, or how you would...
Honestly, that's a fact.
That's why I stay pretty much to myself.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- [Bob] Because I can't...
No.
And got this guy here.
- Marlo.
- Yeah.
Little Marlo. He all right.
But,
I got him by way of his real
owner ODed on drugs, and
that's the fentanyl.
- [Interviewer] Fentanyl,
yeah. That's common.
And what is your drug? Heroin?
- Heroin.
- Heroin, yeah.
Heroin seems to be popular
here in the Tenderloin, right?
- Well, that's because of the fentanyl.
Everybody knows it's evil.
A lot of guys still do it, though.
My old school, no heroin.
I'm happy with it.
- [Interviewer] When did you
first get introduced to heroin?
Was it Vietnam?
- Yeah.
I liked it so much, I actually quit,
because I knew if I kept
doing it, it would kill me.
You know what I mean?
It'd get you.
I'd nod off somewhere and VC or the NDA
would catch up and blow my head off.
So that's why I didn't mess with it.
And,
then about three years ago, I started.
Again.
- Oh, just recently?
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Tell me what your thoughts
on sending young men to war.
- They shouldn't.
That's all there is to it.
The volunteer thing is
fine, but to draft them?
No.
- [Interviewer] It changed
the man's life forever, right?
- Oh, definitely.
Definitely.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And drugs became
like a good distraction
for those guys, right?
- Oh, hell yeah.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And then
the addiction set in,
and the crash course.
- Yeah, they give you a lot of
goddamn really cool weapons.
Rock and roll, daughter doing drugs
They turned her back to it, you know?
- [Interviewer] You
think all of the things
you went through, Vietnam,
losing your wife, things
like that, made you strong?
- They're bad things, they're
bumps in the road, of course.
- [Interviewer] Did
they make you stronger?
- Yeah. I do believe that, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, I pretty much...
People just realize, don't mess with him.
(laughing)
Just leave him alone. He's fine.
Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You don't bother anybody.
They don't bother you.
- No.
- [Interviewer] Did you have
some good years with your wife?
- Oh yes.
Yeah. We were definitely in love.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
- Definitely in love.
Yeah. She was great for me.
- [Interviewer] What was her name?
- Laurie.
How many years were you married?
- Oh, 16 years.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
- Yeah.
- That's wonderful.
But I got to get out of
the TL here soon, though.
Because it's really starting to get bad.
It's getting real bad.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
It's not a good lifestyle.
- Yep.
They're out there robbing people
like you wouldn't believe.
Everybody.
- [Interviewer] It's a
hard environment to be
where everyone is up to no good.
- That's a fact.
Yeah.
I very rarely sleep at night.
- [Interviewer] Why is that?
- Because of it...
- [Interviewer] Just the-
- The robbing you
- [Interviewer] Just all the
other shenanigans going on.
It gets worse at night, of course.
- Yeah.
Now two weeks ago, I'm sitting
there and a car pulled up.
Seven guys got into a gunfight.
Yeah.
You don't get in an environment like that.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. Nobody needs that.
- Huh?
- No one needs that.
- No.
And it's getting worse.
It's getting worse.
- [Interviewer] What do
you think of the future
for our country, or even the planet?
- I think we'll be all right.
We just got to stop
messing around, you know?
We just got to stop it.
We just got to get things right.
Yeah, and work at it a little bit
instead of just picking
sides and battling.
- And fighting.
- The hell with it.
- [Interviewer] All right, Bob.
Thank you so much for sharing your story.
- Okay.
- [Interviewer] I wish you
and Marlo the best of luck.
- Oh, we will.
We will, this is my boy.
- [Interviewer] All right.
- Yes, you don't have to
take me down anywhere.
You can just follow me down the stairs,
it would be wonderful.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I'll do that.
Okay. Thank you, Bob.
- [Bob] So I don't...
Come on, meatball.